now the ukrainian president vladimir
zelensky has condemned comments by the
former german chancellor gerhard
schroeder suggesting that russia wants
to negotiate a solution to its war of
aggression schroder is refusing to cut
his close personal ties with russian
leader vladimir putin and is facing an
investigation by his own party the
social democrats
it was a self-styled diplomatic mission
to the kremlin
vladimir putin's spokesman confirmed
that former german chancellor gerhard
schroeder met the russian president on a
moscow visit last week
in an interview with german media
schroder said that putin wants a
negotiated solution to the war in
ukraine and that the recent grain deal
could be slowly expanded into a
ceasefire
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
made clear what he thought of the former
chancellor's diplomatic efforts
it is simply disgusting when former
leaders of major states with european
values work for russia which is at war
against these values
russia is using these people as
messengers
to say that the terrorist state
allegedly wants negotiations
a long-standing friend of putin's
soon after leaving office in 2005 he
accepted a job with russian energy
company gazprom
and later became chairman of the
supervisory board of another russian
energy giant rosneft
schroeder has refused to distance
himself from the russian leader
in march shortly after russia invaded
ukraine he traveled to moscow to meet
putin
his wife posting this picture of herself
praying for peace with the kremlin in
the background
has been scorned for his continued ties
with russia
some of his privileges as a former
chancellor have been withdrawn and he is
facing an investigation by his party the
social democrats over his kremlin links
for more on the story i'm joined now by
dw politics correspondent nina
hi nina we just heard
vladimir zelinski saying in that report
that putin is using schroder as a
messenger is there any sense at all in
german government circles that the
former chancellor could play a serious
mediation role in this conflict
well zielinski's reaction is pretty much
mirrored here in the german press today
as well people call schroder putin's
puppet et cetera you mustn't forget that
uh gad is suggesting getting naught
stream two so that controversial gas
pipeline we've all been talking about so
much that he's
getting that going to make up for the
lack of gas deliveries via not stream
one from russia but what he doesn't
mention is that he gath schroder himself
is the president of the board of
directors of not stream two so he'd
benefit personally and that is reason
enough to doubt that he could be the
neutral mediator he's pretending to be
and yet he is still the only
high-ranking politician in his party who
still has links to putin but as far as
government circles are concerned
politicians here from the um from his
own party keep telling us that schroder
is acting on his own behalf and
definitely not in the name of the
government it is possible that back in
february when the war first
escalated that some considered using him
as an unofficial mediator but since then
schroder really has completely sidelined
himself here in berlin with statements
that repeat the russian view word by
word and make it look essentially as
though the german government is lying
you've mentioned his party the spd
they've more or less disowned him he's
currently facing an internal
investigation what exactly is it that
his party the spd is investigating
well the spd is looking into 17 official
requests to kick him out of the party
because of his close ties with russia
and in particular with russian
state-owned energy companies so the
party itself says that it is not too
optimistic that they'll be successful in
kicking him out for legal reasons what's
working in favor here of schroeder is
that schroder did leave the supervisory
board of energy giant rosneft in may and
he also didn't accept a nomination to a
post at the supervisory board of gasprom
after a lot of pressure on him so the
sbds say that they will represent the
result of that investigation in a few
days next monday and schroder can then
appeal the decision and the legal battle
could drag on for a while
do you think that with his lobbying on
behalf of putin and the russian gas
injury industry do you think that that
could even lead to him being sanctioned
by the government
it's not looking like it at the moment
the european parliament back in may
spoke out in favor of imposing eu
sanctions on gerhart schroeder because
of his activities at rosneft and then he
did leave rosneft so that's not looking
very likely
dw's nina harza thanks so much for that
you